I do these uh like group meditations
where we activate our heart energies and
we use the power of group intention to
transform our own lives and the planet
the Maharishi effect is you get like 5
000 meditators around the world and they
focus on emoting an energy and setting
that intention when you get lots of
people focused on one outcome it affects
the planet in a way to where it can
decrease violent crimes on the planet by
up to like 70 percent for a certain
period of time there are people that
maybe understand that if you keep people
in fear and in anger and in lower
vibrational emotions that their energy
is scattered it's like they're much
easier to control and I think what's
happening on the planet right now is
people are waking up and I think that
when we come together together with
group intention like that it does the
opposite of what certain people may be
doing to like keep the collective
Consciousness at a certain level I mean
when you look at the media and the fear
that's being projected out into the
world